hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game also from round three of
this year's aim chest preliminaries it
is Vincent kymer vs Magnus Carlsen and
yes these are their uh tour ratings
these are not the standard video ratings
as you can see Magnus is rated over 2
900 but it's interesting this is one of
the few tournaments where Magnus is
playing where there are no 2800 players
so none of the other players are rated
above 27.99 and Magnus is 2 900 so there
are no 2800 players in this tournament
but yeah as the title uh suggests you
guys know everything but it's not that
it happened once in this game it
happened three times at least in this
game so uh without further Ado let's
check it out sorry about not uh not
finishing the video properly in the in
the previous video I have no idea what
happened to my brain in that one uh
really really weird stuff but let's
check it out it's quite the game so
Vincent has the white pieces and he
opens with C4 he goes for the English
opening we have E5 by Magnus and now
this D3 move this is like the fifth most
popular uh move in the position and
Magnus goes for Bishop to B4 check and
already we are down to a few games in
the database with Bishop to D2 Magnus
plays A5 we have knighted the C3 and now
there are some games where Knight the C6
was played but here we have Knight to F6
by Magnus and it is now already as of
move forward that we have a completely
new game
so Vincent continues developing Knight
to F3 puts pressure on the E5 Pawn
Knight the C6 Magnus defends the pawn
and A3 now challenging the bishop and
Magnus trades here he gives up the
bishop pair characters captures and
queen to E7 we have E3 uh you have to
decide how to develop the light Square
Bishop so you're either gonna play E3 uh
not that E3 4 or G3 and Finca to the
bishop Vincent decides for E3 and now
Pawn to A4 uh just uh grabbing more
space on the queen side also maybe at
some point the Knight might be able to
come to B3 but to that it all depends on
what white plays so here Bishop P2
Castles by both players and now we have
D6 we have Rook to C1 and Rook the E8
Knights the D2 and now Pawn to H6 Knight
the E4 and Vincent wants to trade this
Knight Knight captures D captures and
now Pawn to F6 so Vincent does have a
doubled E Pawn here but he has a very
nice control of the center and also the
double e 3 Pawn will be a nice support
for eventually advancing this Pawn to F4
so Bishop to D3 we have Knight to d8 and
now we have Pawn to C5 and this is where
the things
um take a really really unexpected turn
uh Magnus plays D captures on C5 okay
it's a free Pawn but now Magnus has a
double C pawn and also Vincent plays
Bishop to B5 now he will win back the A4
Pawn C6 Bishop characters on A4 and now
it's a very very tricky uh position
Magnus should continue with something
like Bishop the bishop to E6 or maybe
Knight to F7 followed by Bishop to E6
but instead Magnus plays Pawn to B5 and
here we have the first instance of the
Magnus effect because now Vincent has a
very clear way of taking full control of
the game but you have to figure out why
B5 is such a bad move so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
absolute best move for Vincent while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing the B5
Pawn is actually hanging and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
just bishop captress and B5 this is what
Magnus missed uh and uh by extent also
missed by Vincent because now the
captures will be met with Queen D5 check
and the rook and A8 false uh and if you
don't capture the bishop uh there's just
not a good way to play this you just
have to continue the game like nothing
happened and then uh Vincent is just up
a pawn in a much better position has the
bishop pair and he can just start
advancing his past a pawn so this would
be very very close to winning so instead
after Bishop after after B5 Bishop back
to C2 by Vincent he trusted Magnus on
this one Bishop to E6 and now Pawn to F4
we have Knight to F6 S7 Queen to E1 and
now Bishop to C4 now Magnus wants them I
put the bishop on D3 once The Rook comes
to d8 and trade off the bishop pair
because this bishop pair is extremely
strong here also The Rook lift is coming
so you have to start defending so Rook
to F3 as The Rook is hanging now we have
Rook e to d8 and now Rook to G3 we have
Bishop to D3 Magnus has to eliminate
some of the attackers Bishop captures
with Rook captures on D3 and now Queen
to E2 attacking The Rook but to really
re-maneuvering the Queen to G4 to put
pressure on magnus's King side Rook 8 to
d8 Magnus doubles up on the D file and
the queen to G4 now threatening mate in
one so Magnus has to move the Knight and
now F captures an E5 F captress on E5
and now Queen to G6 with some ideas of
Queen captures and H6 as the g-pawn is
pinned uh but Magnus uh solves this by
simply playing Knight to C4 and now if
you play Queen captures on H6 you would
be in a in a whole lot of trouble
because if Queen captures now there's a
rook D1 check and after you trade this
recapture Sandy one Rook capture Sandy
one there's King F2 and now just Queen
to F7 check and now you will either get
checkmated or you block with the rook
and then the queen is hanging so just
captures and that's it if if Rook
captures on F7 King captures on F7 uh
magnets would end up being up a whole
Rook so of course after Knight to C4 uh
Vincent settles for the C6 spawn so
Queen captures on C6 now the B5 Pony
saying as well Knight captures an E3
Queen captures on B5 and now Queen to H4
and all of a sudden a lot of magnus's
pieces are surrounding the white king
with Bishop captures and E5 and now
another really awesome moment um uh in
the game uh Magnus should play Queen
captures on e4 and yes the G7 Pawn is
hanging but Queen captures on e4 is the
only good move for Magnus now the point
is after Rook captures on G7 you
actually play uh King to h8 and there
are no good discoveries I mean it's it
would be crazy to even uh you know think
of playing something like this uh but
you you can't go after the queen because
just Queen captures an E5 the queen is
attacking the bishop that's why Queen to
E4 is so strong and if rookie seven
check you just play King G8 and now uh
White would have to settle for a
repetition because if you go something
like Rook E8 hoping for a captures
captures there's King F7 and again if
Rook to F1 check which of course is
possible Knight captures on F1 Rook
captures a rook capture Sandy eight Rook
capture 78 and now Queen captures on F1
comes with check that's why you give up
the rook and after King Y8 you move the
bishop and this would be more than
enough for a draw as a yes Magnus says a
rogue Winston Vincent would have a
bishop but two extra pawns here there's
no way to actually challenge them so you
would be perfect we find here that's
what you should do however Magnus played
Rook 8 to D7 now defending the G7 pawn
and now again Vincent has such an
elegant way of winning the game but you
again you guys have to spot it so uh
once again feel free to pause the video
and try and try and spot this one while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not being
mesmerized by the Magnus effect and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to C6 this is the move
and now there is no good defense against
Queen to E6 with check and it doesn't
really matter what you play if you try
some Rook D1 ideas for example Rook D1
Chuck root captures on D1 Rook capture
Sun D1 just King F2 and now Knight to G4
check the Rook of course cannot move the
version E5 hangs that's it white wins
easily so what you would have to do
after uh Queen to C6 is uh play uh
something like Queen to H5 this is your
best defense possible but still Queen to
E6 check and there's just no defense
King the H7 will be met with Rook
characters on E3 and now if you capture
The Rook here will be hanging but there
really isn't anything better okay you
can play some like characters captures
then pick up the bishop here but still
Queen F5 check force is a queen trade
and the end game will be winning for
white capture sculptures now you can go
after the pawn but it's not really all
that great if you play Rook D5 just a
for any fruit characters A5 and now
after let's say c for trying to trade
pawns there's a rook A1 now you have to
put the Rook behind the pass Pawn but uh
it's not gonna be all that great now The
Rook can't move for a very very long
time you're just gonna win this Pawn
you're gonna have two connected pass
points on the queen side the king will
be able to roam around it's a very easy
win for white so that's what was
possible but Vincent played Queen
captures on C5 and not Magnus does have
this queen captures on e4 uh we have
Rook to E1 now and not allowing the
Knight to move and now just to Rook to
D1 by Magnus Bishop to C3 guarding on E1
and now we have Knight the G4 Rook
captures anyone was better but this is a
rapid game so a bit of a Vincent effect
here as well Knights the G4 and now we
have Queen to B4 yeah offering a queen
trade Rook 7 into D4 num Magnus plays
the the absolute top move that uh
completely loses the game but again uh
Vincent missed it now of course what can
you play here what's the idea behind
Rook to D4 or Can you capture with the
bishop not really because just Queen
characters I need one Queen characters
and real captures this Checkmate as the
Knight covers the F2 Square hence the
Knight the G4 move but what you have
here is one thing one uh well something
that is very often missed and that is a
very simple check Queen B3 check again
Vincent has the option of just
connecting with the rook and that's it
there's nothing to be done if the king
moves you just pick up the free rook and
if Queen D5 again you don't care just
Queen captures with Chuck root captures
and not Rook captures and G4 uh wins an
entire piece now Magnus Vincent is just
up a full bishop and that's it
completely winning game so uh a third
time the Magnus effect was in effect and
now after this Rook 7 to four events and
place Rook captures on G4 and now Magnus
continues to Rook captures anyone check
Bishop captures on E1 and now Queen
captures on G4 we have Queen to B3 with
check Vincent finds it but a few moves
too late King to h8 and now Queen to F3
offering a queen trade but Magnus now
declines there's no reason for him to
trade he could trade but then the bishop
and two connected past pawns on the
queen side Magnus feels that he can do a
lot better he can
paralyze the bishop he can go after the
pawns if he can eliminate at least one
of these pawns then it will be much
better for him so Queen to E3 attacking
The Rook not just Queen to B1 and now
what is the what is the meaning of this
why is why is this so so great well of
course if the Rook is captured then this
is mating one so uh after Queen to B1 we
have King the F1 guarding the bishop but
not just Queen captures and B2
eliminating one of the pawns with H3 now
Queen to B5 with check King to G1 Rook
to D3 attacking the queen and now Queen
to F2 we have Queen to E5 now trying to
get
um uh the the rook and queen cooperating
to go after the best report to form some
sort of a checkmating a series of moves
we have G3 here it's very hard to play
something like a bishop to D2 might
still pose problems but after G3 there's
just no going back Queen T4 by Magnus
now assuming all of the important
squares H4 and now King the H7 we have
pawned the A4 by Vincent but Magnus
ignores it just goes Rook to E3
challenges the bishop Bishop to A5 and
now Rook to E2 we have Queen to F1 you
have to guard against Checkmate and now
Rook the B2 by Magnus you could also go
for Queen D4 it's a very nice idea
because it forces King to H1 and then
you go Queen to D3 with unstoppable
threats just let's say or a rook h a
rook H2 check picks up the queen because
even if Rook H2 King G1 you can still
play Rook to H1 check and force the king
away from the queen if the bishop moves
from the defense of D1 Square even Queen
to e for checkfall by Rook D1 so there
really aren't any options here but okay
Magnus uses a different idea Rook to B2
we have Bishop back to E1 now as Rook to
B1 was coming and now Rook the E2 again
goes after the bishop Bishop to F2 and
now Rook to A2 going after the pawn uh
Queen the G2 offering a queen trade but
now Magnus more than happily traits
captures captures and now he doesn't go
for the pawn because there's just no
rush and you don't want to allow whites
to start pushing on on the king side
playing something like H5 so Magnus just
plays H5 himself keeping the pawns where
they are uh we have A5 now and now King
to G6 bringing the king into the game
King F3 and pinning so now you are
hoping to defend the pawn but now
magnets will just gobble it up so here
Bishop D4 Rook to A3 with Chuck King to
F4 now Rook A4 uh going after the bishop
King E5 now King to F7 and Bishop to E3
we have Rook A5 check King to F4 and now
King to E6 we have Pawn to G4 and Magnus
now plays Rook to a for with check with
King to G5 wins and can now only hope
for some sort of a stalemate uh Rook
captures on G4 King characters on H5 and
now King the F5 boxing in the white king
Bishop to G5 hoping uh to maybe create
some sort of a fortress uh if you go for
something like G G6 check your king H6
and it's very very unclear if it's
possible to win this probably this would
be a draw but Magnus finds the absolute
cleanest solution Rook to G2 and it was
in this position on move 64 that Vincent
kaimer resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done because what
follows or what would follow if Vincent
hadn't resigned is uh well nothing short
of amazing uh just to give you uh an
example let's say if you have to move
the bishop you can't move the king so
let's say you play something Bishop to
D2 you don't really care uh you you
you're even offering the bishop but they
just Rook the G6 and now after the
bishop moves again uh now of course you
will see the Checkmate it's it's a very
nice one of course The Rook the H6 and
there is only one move you have to
accept the rook and once the bishop
captures G6 is Checkmate so truly
spectacular stuff uh but yeah Vincent
had okay the the first time uh he he
could have seized the advantage after
this B5 was played this was okay this
was a much better position but it
doesn't mean that you will win second
time here after Magnus played this Rook
a rook here move
uh again Vincent could have seized the
advantage with Queen to C6 uh probably
would win this but the third time that
Vincent missed this when uh this Rook to
D4 moves played when he missed Queen to
B3 this is just a clean piece there
there's no way out of this so we often
see Magnus affecting times uh maybe
happens once in a game but here three
times in a game that's that's that's
incredible uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it never trust
your opponent regardless of how strong
you think he is that they will most
likely make mistakes uh you know
throughout the entire game so stay you
know be careful about that uh I would
like to yeah congrats uh thank
congratulations Dr tacon uh Francis sir
Duncan weinkel and the woman life
freedom for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day